okay so this is my solo review of
Maleficent if he didn't catch the other
v-log they're pretty much rob is uh head
deep in submissions we got an insane
amount so he wasn't able to show up for
this one or the x-men one oh but he he
pretty much had no interest to see
Maleficent anyway so so I went and
checked it out and the short version is
it's not very good but I think anyone
that went into seeing this movie I saw
the preview said hey I want to see that
that that looks good
you'll be fine you know it's it makes no
sense
I mean it's based on a story that
already makes little sense but it's a
fairy tale from years and years ago and
Disney adapted it in many respects had
it make even less sense but whatever it
was still artistically pleasing and had
a lot of cool characters now you have
this one which is based on the Disney
version it's whatever an update or
quote-unquote more adult version and it
just makes even less sense I mean there
are so many things that don't add up in
this you have Maleficent was a fairy and
wings and design really cool comes
across this boy this human boy the two
kingdoms are split between fairies and
people the people are just dicks for no
reason at least they're led by a dick
King the boy falls in love with
Maleficent but just goes back to the
kingdom becomes a dick and the king says
whoever can kill Maleficent will get the
king hood because I'm dying so he goes
he can't kill Maleficent but he takes
her wings while he knocks her out says I
killed her the king gives him the
kingdom and Maleficent is pissed so she
now rules her kingdom and makes it all
dark and grim hears about the birth of
his child you know the drill
puts a curse on her and what the King
like in the story has the baby to the
the three fairies
Maleficent finds her right away
I mean it's not even like a pause like
they just they go to the cottage and you
just see Maleficent walk up to the
window and I I think I joined my wife
and I just said well that was fast I
mean the movie it's like the last third
she finds her or 16 years later so that
made me laugh and the fairies are really
stupid in this and I kind of don't like
that because they were very entertaining
characters and they were very thoughtful
characters in the original and they're
just dumbbells and I'm either really too
dumb they're way too dumb and they're
there half the time when they're fairies
they're CG and it's not needed the CG in
this movie looks really it doesn't look
bad it looks fake it looks really
unbelievably fake but I'll get to that
it's like artistically it still kind of
looks nice um so those are that kind of
it but they look really fake and
Maleficent because the fairies are so
dumb I mean that really is the reason uh
is practically raising the baby and wait
I don't get it I don't care why she's
watching it she's pretty much trolling
them like she'll just make it rain
inside the fairies never questioned it
they just they're pretty much the Three
Stooges they'll just like pull each
other's hair and go on it's really
Damini if you like if you like the
fairies at all from the the original
Disney film you can be really pissed off
so Maleficent practically raises this
baby I mean like stuff like she's
walking off a cliff and the fairies
don't see you so Maleficent catches her
and say I mean it's they're doing the
wicked route I think most people going
in know that where she's not gonna be
all bad I think she's not even gonna
really be that bad um and years pass and
she grows up grows up into Aurora played
by I guess a Fanning sister who i'll
give real credit for is not that bad
because this is not a well-written
character this is just a happy go like
oh everything is enchanted here birds
fly on my hands and tweet I mean it
she's written like that but she
plays it well she is actually a very
happy very you know interesting to watch
actress honestly you know and I like to
that even if she's she's very
good-looking but she's not like it you
know damn you know anything like that
I mean she's you know an above-average
person you know looking person but it's
like it her personality you know just
shines through and makes her this really
sort of interesting beautiful character
in a strange way um so I give her a lot
of credit to that actress I think she
did a very good job with nothing nothing
and she really pulled this through so uh
I give her a lot of credit for that um
so she grows up thinks Maleficent is her
favorite godmother which is cute I dig
that um of course Maleficent forms a
friendship with her she tries to take
the curse away but she can't and if I go
any more past that I mean we'll be
getting into spoilers um a lot of it
follows the traditional story except
pretty obviously Maleficent is gonna be
you know still be the good person
throughout the whole thing and the king
when this king is a really bad actor
sorry the the guy that got to play the
king for his first off and I hate
talking like this but his voice is
ridiculous it's a really bad voice and
it's okay I'll put on the writing too
he's not well written there's he set up
to be a very interesting character but
that's all current sort of sidelined and
just he's just kind of a dick now and
he's just kind of crazy now and he's got
this really really thick scotch axe and
this really really high pitched voice
and it's you know it's if you have as I
don't know something about the
combination of all the things that went
into this guy did not work you know and
there's a lot of eccentric performances
out there that can still you know even
out Bryan Cranston and Godzilla is very
eccentric and very over-the-top but it
evens out I mean it works out very well
this does not and I was just laughing
every time he's on screen um and I'm
really sorry you know I feel bad for
saying that but he's just he's laughably
bad
but again he's not he's not written very
well either so so there is kind of that
and yes it pretty much makes no sense
whatsoever my thought is that anyone who
want to see this movie though sees
Miletus it will mean Maleficent's a good
person maybe there's sort of this more
to the story that I never thought of
when ever and I just I just want to see
a fairy tale I want to see a a pretty
landscape and magic and romance and
kissing it's fine if you're just looking
for that and you're pretty lenient um
because there is a part of me that's
it's not getting good reviews I mean
it's I mean not getting destroyed but
but it's not getting very good reviews
and I see why but a part of me is like
you know it's it's not that bad
I mean again if you want to look at from
logic wise and the effects look totally
fake and that but it's it's a freaking
fairy tale and I think the people who
want to see this you know who would want
to see this movie probably get what
they're looking for
fine I think they would really dislike
the three fairies I think that is the
one thing they'd probably be pissed off
at I think everything else is totally
serviceable it's a very nice-looking
movie the designs are are very nice for
the most part you get one or two
characters like the big eyes are like
the woven you kind of really eyes and
say okay but like the design of
Maleficent is great Angelina Jolie looks
great as Maleficent I think this whole
movie was made just to get cool shots of
Maleficent cuz there's like a dozen
there's a dozen I'm like well then that
would should go in the trailer that
should go in the trailer that should I
mean there's a ton she looks the part
I'll get to her performance in a second
I like to just wrap up about the rest of
the movie here so I think it's something
where there are people that just wanna
go see a movie and they just want to see
a fairy tale they just want to see
something you know really magical you
know like or has magic I should say and
romantic elements and this has that and
fairytales are not usually that embedded
much in logic anyway
so it's it's passable in that sense if
you're looking for something more medias
really gonna make the story more
interesting and be really
psychologically interesting and bringing
us something new it you're not gonna
really get that you can serve pick and
choose what elements they're stealing
from and the look I forget
I don't know this artist name sadly but
you've seen his books and this is the
guy who his artwork is mainly just fairy
so two good-looking fairies and bad
fairies and ugly fairies and pretty
fairies and I wanna say it was maybe
even used in the Dark Crystal I'm not
sure I could be wrong about that I mean
don't quote me on this stuff
but it has that feel to it maybe the
guy's the designer I don't know and I'm
so sorry I don't know the name but I'm
sure people are gonna tell me in the
comments but it has that look to it and
and it's it's nice and it's a little
different from sort of traditional
Disney stuff but it's also mixed in with
I said you got the big dopey I do you
know toad people or whatever and the
really you know cutesy wutesy fairies
you know the three fairies and stuff so
I mean there's all the Disney isms in
there too um so I think you can kind of
get a feel whether or not this is what
you're looking for um you know if you
are very lenient and you just want a
fairy tale it's fine you know there's
nothing insultingly bad about a side I
think from the three fairies and well
like I said what's a while the king you
know can really you serve rubbing your
eye like oh man is this guy but you know
they're trying to give him a story like
this psychological you know tear down
it's just not done that great um
Angelina Jolie it's funny cuz for years
I've heard people say at least critics
you know say oh she's awful she is just
so bad and so terrible and I didn't get
it I didn't really get what they were
talking about because I would see her in
a movie I'd just be like fine you know I
mean nothing really stands out but you
know maybe it's okay and I realize that
was the thing I was trying to think
what's an Angelina Jolie performance
where I said that was really good like
that really stuck out it she was like oh
my god I was
all invested in what was going on with
her because it was just so unbelievable
I can't think of one um she is a totally
serviceable actress and that's really
about it I I don't know that counts is
terrible because it's like we've seen
terrible okay we've seen really bad
acting my job and I think a lot of other
critics - I mean they you see a lot of
bad actresses you know not like oh I
don't know if I totally believe the
person or gods liked it no I mean like
how did you get out of high school with
that act how did you do a school play
with that acting so I don't think she's
that but I do see what people were
talking about with that whole thing um I
think she she definitely has the look
and that's not just the makeup you know
or or the CG or anything I mean like you
know a good maybe half of her delivery
and just her you know just her sort of
glares and stuff like that and I I know
the effects they do I know makeup I know
CG Photoshop and study it's not just
that I think she actually does get
awesome legitimately good stares she has
one or two well-read cold lines um you
know I like when she first he bring she
brings this bird turns his burden to a
boy pretty much to do her bidding and
there's something really cool about just
she talked very quick very fast what did
they call you instead I mean it was like
very affirmative very very cool I was
like okay like some of this she's doing
very well none of it's like horrible so
when she screams it's like okay there's
no I'm not buying that at all you know I
it's like no there's I'm not buying it
but it it's not horrible it's not
terrible but I if you could if you like
her in other films you like you're fine
in this if you're not a fan of her this
isn't gonna sway you but I don't know
I'm glad I saw it because there was
enough enough cool things in how it
visually looked that I real I did enjoy
that um and like I said it's it's not
that the CG looks real it looks
unbelievably fake
but it's very stylized and very
nice-looking and it was just creative
enough for me so I'm glad I saw it even
though I know it's technically not a
good movie and like I said if if you're
just looking for a bit of romance kind
of a touching story with some magic that
and you're just really lenient you're
not looking for plot threads or good you
know like you're not gonna nitpick
performances and stuff I mean that's
that's what I do it's a living you know
I mean it is my living it's just always
always seen films but when you get to
the good ones it's even greater um
but yeah if you're just very laid-back
want to see a fairy tale and aren't too
picky it's fine you know I don't think
anything in there was gonna especially
piss you off but if you're looking for
something much deeper and interesting
bring something new you're probably not
gonna get here so that's that's my guess
so guys that's about it yeah yeah those
are my thoughts on the movies and
hopefully I'll be back with even more
movies to talk about take care